madame monsieur bonsoir aussi les titres
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 14 août
alain bernard n'a pas failli dans
l'épreuve reine de la natation le 100 m
nage libre il a été sacré ce matin
champion olympique en 47 secondes et 21
centièmes suicide d'un jeune handicapé
rémy salvat 23 ans avait demandé qu'on
l'aide à mettre fin à ses jours
il a finalement choisi sun un cure jt
une surdose de médicaments sa mère
régine sera en direct dans ce journal
l'économie française en panne au
deuxième trimestre la croissance est en
recul peut être le signe de récession
tout dépendra les résultats du troisième
trimestre dans le caucase c'est les
armes se sont tues les forces russes
occupent toujours la ville de gori en
géorgie condolezza rice après avoir
rencontré nicolas sarkozy en france sera
ce soir à tbilissi le festival de la
roque d'anthéron les plus grands
pianistes se retrouvent chaque année
dans le luberon et où les concerts se
donne en plein air à la tombée du jour
se poursuit jusqu'au 22 août
il était au rendez-vous le spectaculaire
à la bernard champion olympique dans
l'épreuve reine de la natation qui a
écouté le sourire aux lèvres retentir la
marseillaise sur place julien avaient
des taux et jean-marc boucle
100 m pour l'éternité à 25 ans alain
bernard est le nouveau roi de l'épreuve
reine
une immense émotion envahi le clan
français
le géant d'1 mètre 96 ou en larmes à la
sortie du bassin
ça fait des années des anecdotes et que
je travaille c'est pour vivre des
moments comme ça
merci merci j'ai réalisé mon plus beau
jour de ma vie vraiment vraiment passé
un ex quelques minutes plus tôt ultimes
conseils de son entraîneur
les deux hommes ont consacré les quatre
dernières années à cette finale
olympique qui réunit les huit meilleurs
sprinteurs de la planète
immédiatement la course se résume à un
duel entre le français champion d'europe
et eamon sullivan
l'australien bonnets jaunes détenteur du
record du monde vire en tête à mi-course
mais le français s'accroche à son rêve
que vous vous dites dans les 20 derniers
mètres quand vous êtes au coude à coude
avec souvenons nous par les jeunes dit
non c'est pas toi c'est pas toi c'est
moi qui le touchait premier voile à 47
secondes et 21 centièmes à l'arrivée
alain bernard conserve une main d'avancé
sur l'australien ces quelques centièmes
qui lui avait manqué pour décrocher l'or
dans le relais troisième nageur
tricolore champion olympique après jean
boiteux et laure manaudou
ses proches ont du mal à réaliser
c'est beaucoup d'émotion et voilà on
repense nombreuses années de travail
qu'ils ont dit
depuis quand mondiale omm votre bien
tous les deux chambres est ce qu'il ya
des mots pour exprimer tout ça pour les
inventer je parle pour
au delà de la de tous âges c'est qu'on
donne du bonheur à tellement de gens
le champion olympique quitte
tranquillement la piscine après avoir
reçu par téléphone les félicitations du
président sarkozy ses amis l'attendent
pour le congratuler
plus rien ne sera comme avant pour alain
bernard
là haut au panthéon du sport français
est très loin de pékin au tour des
parents d'alain bernard dans les
hautes-alpes et tout le village s'était
réveillée pour suivre des preuves en
direct pas de chance aux moments clés le
drame un câble il est branché la
télévision c'est un le temps est
suspendu arnaud comté gilles gard sa
famille et ses amis se sont réunis dans
la salle des fêtes du village à pékin
alain bernard s'apprête à s'élancer
4h49 stupeur au départ
pas d'image ce problème technique il
n'ya plus que le soir
ap 47 secondes angoisse eliane la maman
étant là son fils est champion olympique
et mon petit frère qui est champion les
filets
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient quand il
s'entraînait avec nous à aubagne ils
étaient déjà plus petit que nous et déjà
ils nous tiraient bien labour donc on a
bien vu qu'il avait déjà des qualités
après il a eu une montée en puissance
exceptionnelle exceptionnel destin d'un
enfant que tout le monde a vu grandir
dans le village d'origine de la famille
bernard baisse est très émouvant moi
j'ai eu ma petite larme comme beaucoup
d'ailleurs à châteauvieux aujourd'hui
ici alain bernard est déjà un héros
et dire qu'ils pourraient décrocher
samedi sa deuxième médaille d'or il faut
remonter à 1957 pour retrouver une
médaille d'or française en natation
masculine
c'était jean boiteux qui avait remporté
le 400 m nage libre
l'image de son père sautant dans la
piscine le béret sur la tête pour
féliciter son fils alors que tous les
concurrents n'étaient pas encore arrivés
ce qui a failli le disqualifier a fait
le tour du monde
on écoute l'ancien champion olympique
qui a revécu son âge d'or on est dans un
petit nuage d'abord parce que sait on à
balard et de batailler dans l'eau tout
ça pendant des années c'est quand même
le titre suprême pour maintenant mon
sport ça arrive que tous les quatre ans
et c'est certainement pour l'immense
joie une immense fierté
on est champion olympique de l'olympia
il est champion les beats il sera
toujours champion olympique mais même
s'ils gagnent par la prochaine fois il
est toujours champion même prix voilà et
ça ça reste à vie alain bernard c'est le
sportif qui rassemble tous les suffrages
ce garçon sympathique d'aubagne jambes
armes quand il n'est pas dans les
bassins et qui avant de se lancer dans
la natation était de l'aveu même de sa
mère plutôt maigrichon il a bien changé
portrait signé clair les signes et
frédéric bazille
on le surnomme le géant blond des
bassins rationnelle méticuleux à 25 ans
alain bernard ne lève jamais le pied à
coup de séances de musculation et de
longueur cette saison il aura nager plus
de 2000 kilomètres ça depuis des années
c'est vraiment ma passion le but ultime
c'est d'aller aux jeux c'est de faire
quelque chose au jeu et et pour ça il
faut rester concentré pour passer il
faut passer là dit il faut pas dire on a
fait le gamin d'aubagne a fait du chemin
peut-il n'aime pas l'eau et apprend à
nager pour faire plaisir à sa mère plus
tard c'est son physique qui pose
problème selon son ostéopathe son corps
est raide comme du bois mais le monde de
la natation guette le déclic il aurait
pu arriver aux jeux d'athènes malade il
doit déclarer forfait
en même temps c'est une importante du
jeu en mars 2008 aux championnats
d'europe c'est la consécration tant
attendue du colosse il enchaîne les
excès de vitesse record du monde de
l'époque sur 50 et 100 m nage libre
ces huit années de travail son physique
hors normes ont fini par payer
aujourd'hui le grand gaillard est le roi
du sprint et le nageur le plus rapide de
la gendarmerie c'est sûr où il prépare
une possible reconversion
et pendant ce temps laure manaudou sauve
l'honneur elle s'est qualifiée pour les
demi finales du 200 m dos sa nouvelle
spécialité mais en arrivant que 10e des
séries pour parvenir en finale il lui
faudra être dans les huit meilleurs
temps
elle a annoncé qu'elle ferait une longue
pause dans sa carrière et ses
entraînements faut dire que laure
manaudou a d'ores et déjà beaucoup perdu
dans ces jo de pékin ne reviendront à la
fin de ce journal sur les autres temps
forts de cette journée olympique
il s'appelait rémy il avait 23 ans
souffrait d'une maladie dégénérative
rare il s'est suicidé dimanche dernier
en prenant des médicaments auparavant il
avait écrit au président de la
république pour lui demander une aide au
suicide nicolas sarkozy lui a
personnellement répondu
et face à ce qu'il a considéré comme une
fin de non recevoir le jeune homme a
choisi de mettre fin à ses jours
les dix sièges gendre et virginie
travers une cérémonie religieuse à la
mémoire de rémy salvat le jeune homme
lourdement handicapée qui s'est suicidé
dimanche dernier en surdosant ces
médicaments il halète avoir 24 ans donc
elle toujours qu'on voyait c'était
vraiment un message d'espoir pour tout
le monde parce que il montrait jamais
qu'il avait mal ou qui se sentait pas
bien la passion de rennes-ii l'aïkido
qu'il continue à pratiquer malgré la
maladie dégénérative qui lui ronge et
ses muscles depuis l'âge de 6 ans une
équipe de france 2 l'avait rencontrée
dans le cadre d'une émission diffusée à
la rentrée prochaine
il confiait alors ses angoisses tu vas
tu le buzz en mai dernier
rémy avait écrit au président sarkozy
afin qu'on lui permette de mourir je
vous demande de laisser de côté votre
avis personnel et d'arrêter d'être sourd
il faut que la loi change quatre jours
avant son suicide il a reçu une réponse
de l'elysée pour des raisons
philosophiques et personnel je crois
qu'il ne nous appartient pas que nous
n'avons pas le droit d'interrompre
volontairement la vie avant de se donner
la mort rémy a tenu à laisser un ultime
message à ses parents
quelqu'un m'a demandé si j'étais soulagé
non il n'y a aucun soulagement
ries mr e tu avoir encore devant lui des
moments de vie de joie de rire
une autopsie du corps de rémy salvat a
été réalisé une enquête est ouverte
relancé le débat autour de l'euthanasie
et du suicide assisté a été ces derniers
mois
la raison de vivre du jeune homme est
aussi sa raison mûri et vous l'avez vu
rémy salvat été suivis pendant plusieurs
semaines par une équipe de tournage de
tony comiti qui l'a filmé lui a permis
de s'exprimer comme il le souhaitait et
vous verrez ce document sur france 2 à
la rentrée dans l'émission cellule de
crise
aujourd'hui c'est donc la loi léonetti
d'accompagnement de fin de vie qui
s'applique elle permet de laisser mourir
les patients mais pas l'euthanasie
active le point sur ce que prévoit cette
fois avec perrine bonnet et nice brésil
l'implication de marie humbert et du dr
chaussoy dans la mort de vincent en 2003
a provoqué un grand débat dans l'opinion
publique
jean leonetti député ump alors chargé
d'une mission sur l'euthanasie qui
aboutit à la loi qui porte son nom que
permet la loi
elle permet ce qu'on appelle
l'euthanasie passive le médecin peut
décider sans crainte de poursuites
l'arrêt des traitements actifs de son
patient il peut aussi donner un
traitement antidouleur à des doses
élevées au risque d'abréger la vie que
ne permettait elle pas elle ne permet
pas l'euthanasie active telle qu'elle
est autorisée en belgique ou aux pays
bas
un médecin français ne peut pas donner
directement la mort aux patients ni lui
prescrire un produit dans le but
d'abréger la vie c'est-à-dire assister
un suicide
comment peut évoluer la loi chantal
sébire où le jeune rémy salvat n'était
pas en fin de vie ils réclamaient
justement le droit au suicide assisté
jean leonetti pense que la loi peut être
amélioré mais en aucun cas dans ce sens
si la demande c'est je ne veux pas de
dialogue
je ne veux pas de soins je veux
simplement que vous m'apportez la mort
parce que je la réclame que j'ai décidé
de ne plus vivre et bien aujourd'hui
et je l'espère pro longtemps il n'y a
pas une loi qui donne un droit à mourir
à toute personne qui le réclament
en ce qui concerne le rôle des proches
la loi leonetti ne s'en mêle pas c'est à
la justice de l'apprécier le choix du
suicide reste de toute façon en france
une liberté individuelle
il entrevoit en duplex régine salvat la
maman de rémy bonsoir madame vous saviez
évidemment qu'il voulait qu'il voulait
en finir
vous pensez qu'il a voulu vous épargne
en choisissant de mourir seul d'abord je
vais préciser que je ne savais pas que
rémy voulait en finir là là maintenant
je sais que rémy voilà rémy avait une
maladie évolutive lourdes il était très
lucide et savait qu'un jour peut-être
dans quelques mois peut-être dans deux
trois ans et serait hyper v tous ses
moyens qui souffrirait énormément qui
risquait d'être saunier de son corps et
de ressentir des douleurs et de vraiment
se retrouver grave à traire jusqu'à un
jour mourir si on ne nourrissait pas que
son coeur battrai donc remy ce qu'ils
demandaient rémy ce qu'il avait voulu
demander ce n'est pas ce n'était pas
l'un maintenant je suis déprimé où je
vais mal et je demande qu'on qu'on me
permette de mourir que quelqu'un vienne
me même me tuer carrément c'était de
dire dans des situations exceptionnelles
lorsqu'il ya trop de souffrance lorsque
l'être se peut se retrouver prisonnier
des années et des années parce que c'est
le cas actuellement dans cette
souffrance jeu il faudrait qu'une des
équipes médicales et le droit
effectivement d'apporter l'euthanasie ou
ce qu'il appelait lui un autre moment
dans ses paroles le suicide assisté
madame son fils y voilà son suicide
évidemment a été rendu public est-ce que
c'était votre votre choix est ce que
c'est parce que votre fils voulait que
la loi change
c'était le choix de rémi nous n'étions
absolument pas au courant
nous n'avons pas imaginé un instant
ne serait-ce que le soir même que rémy
pourrait commettre un tel geste
il avait depuis trois mois une évolution
effectivement rapide de pertes de
possibilité
il savait que par exemple les perdu
l'usagé d'un bras
en l'espace de 8 15 jours et il a dû
avoir peur de que le même problème lui
arrive et se dire que s'ils s'il
souhaitait partir s'il est avec trauma
c'était trop détruit il ne puisse plus
les fermiers même je me dis ça mais
voilà c'est pas de répondre c'est le
choix de rémy merci beaucoup à l'âme
d'avoir surmonté votre chagrin et
d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions merci et courage à vous un
coup de froid sur l'activité économique
française pour la première fois depuis
2002 la production nationale ralenti
recul même par rapport au trimestre
précédent c'est le contrecoup d'une
possible récession mondiale et qui est
peut-être à nos portes comme nous
l'expliquent romain mais si éric de
lannion rentrée anticipée et réunion dès
lundi entre françois fillon et christine
lagarde
car la croissance économique est en
berne au deuxième trimestre le pib de la
france a reculé de 0,3 pour cent une
première depuis six ans même constat
pour l'ensemble de la zone euro la
croissance baisse de 0,2 pour cent le
gouvernement y voit la conséquence de la
crise financière mondiale et refuse
l'idée d'une récession mais tous les
indicateurs économiques sont au rouge
faute de pouvoir d'achat la consommation
des ménages s'essouffle depuis plusieurs
mois alors que les prix ont augmenté de
3,6 pour cent sur un an
de son côté la production industrielle a
chuté de 1,4 pour cent au deuxième
trimestre et le commerce extérieur
affiche un déficit record
la conjoncture est sombre mais les
économistes voient quelques raisons
d'espérer
le prix du pétrole baisse cette baisse
du prix du pétrole
elle a été suivie de baisse moins forte
mais debès quand même sur les matières
premières alimentaires ce qui signifie
qu on pourrait avoir une décrue de
l'inflation à l'horizon de la fin de
l'année la croissance en 2008
s'annoncent d'ores et déjà faible bien
en dessous des 2% rêvé en début d'année
par le gouvernement et pour aider les
ménages les plus modestes le
gouvernement a décidé de relever le
plafond des ressources qui donne droit
aux tarifs sociaux du gaz et de
l'électricité 2 million de foyers
environ pour pouvoir en bénéficier
reportage juliette guérin et alain
rocacher alexandra gauthier vit seule
avec son fils salariés à temps partiel
elle gagnait 780 euros par mois elles
bénéficient du tarif social de
l'électricité une économie de 8 euros
chaque mois une euros par mois c'est
vrai que c'est pas énorme tout cumulé et
ben ça peut faire un cadeau plus
important une des choses comme ça et
c'est un que c'est c'est quand même très
appréciable de pouvoir faire plaisir à
son enfant
les foyers les plus modestes peuvent en
moyenne espérer une réduction de 75
euros par an sur leur facture
d'électricité
jusqu'à maintenant pour en bénéficier il
fallait gagner moins de 460 euros par
mois
edf vient de relever le plafond à 620
euros majorée en fonction du nombre de
personnes à charge mais cela reste en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
un regret pour les associations on voit
bien qu'en s'adresse à des situations
extrêmement modestes à des personnes qui
de toutes les manières auront de plus en
plus de mal à accéder aux tarifs de
l'énergie
donc ça pose le problème aujourd'hui de
la politique tarifaire en matière
d'énergie gaz de france s'appuiera
pourtant sur les mêmes critères pour
appliquer son nouveau tarif social une
déduction de 17 à 118 euros par an en
fonction de la consommation
une petite compensation en quatre ans le
gaz a augmenté de 50% dans le caucase la
situation reste extrêmement tendue en
dépit des efforts diplomatiques déployés
par les européens les américains les
forces russes occupent toujours au gori
en géorgie en contradiction avec
l'accord qu'ils ont signé avec nicolas
sarkozy au nom de l'ue
européenne sur place voyez ce reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux loïc de la
mornais il est libre d'aoun et yann
moines des mines patibulaires un style
entre forbans et militaires voici une
image rare des milices sud hausse
etienne
ces groupes armés qui agissent plus ou
moins sous contrôle russe dans une ville
de gori laissé à l'anarchie ce matin ils
ont arrêté ce groupe de photographes
pour voler leurs véhicules
l'intervention d'un journaliste russie
fait renoncer ces hommes + bandits que
soldat des meurtres des viols des
pillages de banque ont été rapportés
sans qu'on puisse les confirmés à
l'entrée de la ville la presse interroge
le général russe qui commande la place
qu'est ce que vous croyez moi je
m'occupe de la situation globale
je suis pas un petit garçon qui fait
mumuse à devoir protéger chaque voiture
vous les journalistes vous raconter
toujours n'importe quoi vous dites que
la ville est détruite
bon oui il ya eu quelques bombes mais la
ville tient quand même de goût la
situation est imprévisible
cette journaliste georges yen est
victime d'un tir de sniper en plein
direct télévisé elle a eu chaud la balle
lui a juste effleuré le bras
la police géorgienne massés à l'entrée
de la ville attend le bon vouloir des
russes pour entrer rétablir l'ordre
ils disent qu'on pourrait vouloir les
doubler en faisant entrer nos forces de
sécurité ils sont très suspicieux il
faut y aller doucement en fin de journée
policiers géorgiens soldats russes font
une jonction symbolique pour gérer ce
point de contrôle ensemble mais les
voitures de police n'irons pas plus loin
que les tanks russes
l'armée russe contrôler cette zone mais
les pillages de bandes armées continuent
à rendre la région très dangereuse
il faudra sans doute plusieurs jours
avant que des observateurs
internationaux puis se rendent à ching
valley la capitale de l'ossétie du sud
pour y faire enfin un bilan fiable des
victimes de cette guerre
et côté russe on fait valoir le droit
des populations réclamer leur autonomie
si le city du nord est rattachée à la
russie celle du sud fait théoriquement
partie de la géorgie et la plupart des
habitants ont fui cette province pour se
réfugier dans nord le secrétaire général
de l'onu ban ki-moon s'est dit
je dit extrêmement préoccupé par la
situation humanitaire en géorgie
reportage dans un camp de réfugiés
avec laurent boussier et sergueï rogov
c'est un camp de transit comme il en
existe plusieurs à la frontière entre
l'ossétie du sud et l'ossétie du nord un
camp où depuis une semaine son passé
plus de six mille réfugiés
majoritairement des femmes et des
enfants qui ont fui à l'arrivée des
militaires géorgiens on s'est caché dans
la forêt pendant deux jours avec nos
enfants
seul on n'avait rien à manger ici ils
sont accueillis avait conforté prise en
charge par les membres du ministère
russe des situations d'urgence
bien qu'habitant une région située sur
le territoire de la géorgie
ils ont tous un passeport russe et tous
racontent la peur et les destructions
des premiers jours de la guerre on est
parti au début des bombardements qui
avait déjà sept personnes tuées
distribution de vêtements et de
nourriture image classique d'un camp de
réfugiés
mais pour ceux qui sont arrivés
aujourd'hui c'est surtout la première
nuit en sécurité sous la tente
quand les enfants dorment les adultes
parlent de l'avenir mais sans illusion
les géorgiens sont proches de nous ils
sont nos voisins vide c'est normal mais
penser que le site du sud c'est la
georgie c'est très difficile à
comprendre quand tous ces réfugiés
souhaitent évidemment rentrer chez eux
le plus rapidement possible mais si le
cessez le feu qui a l'air de tenir à peu
près depuis deux jours leur donne bon
espoir
il n'est pas question pour eux de
repasser sous tutelle géorgienne tous
veulent plus que jamais rester russe et
la secrétaire d'état américaine
condoleezza rice s'est longuement
entretenu aujourd'hui avec le président
français nicolas sarkozy au fort de
brégançon européens et américains
partagent la même analyse sur la
situation dans le caucase et réclame une
issue rapide du conflit et jean-marc
ellouze loin d'un conflit où les
belligérants reste toujours face à face
la secrétaire d'état américaine
condoleezza rice est venu cet après-midi
faire le point avec nicolas sarkozy
avant de se rendre à son tour en géorgie
remerciements à la france et à l'europe
pour leur médiation à chaud et un nouvel
appel insistant à moscou le président
russe a affirmé que les opérations
militaires se sont arrêtés nous
souhaiterions qu'il tienne parole et que
ces opérations s'arrête on n'arrête pas
comme ça les choses sur le terrain ça va
mieux si demain monsieur saccage phyllis
signent le document que nous avons
négocié avec monsieur medvedev
alors pour homps amorcer le retrait des
troupes russes
c'est ce qui est en cause au lendemain
de son escapade française madame rice
soumettra au président géorgien
la dernière mouture de l'accord négocié
entre l'europe et les russes un accord
compliqué une trêve fragile mais
pourquoi ce refus j'ai quelques instants
de légèreté avant de reprendre le
collier
depuis plusieurs jours des policiers
venant de plusieurs pays européens
patrouille dans paris aux côtés de leurs
collègues français
il est des touristes mais parfois aussi
interviennent deux policiers un italien
et un belge ont ainsi aidé à interpeller
un pickpocket dans le métro ils ne sont
comme neufs pourtant à circuler dans
paris
hakim abdel khaled et virginie travers
l'europe policière est en marche aux
côtés de policiers français
fernando port hinault et membres de la
police via italienne avec son uniforme
ils patrouillent lui aussi sur les
champs-elysées sa mission assister les
nombreux touristes italiens
on a aidé formage de compatriotes
vos données des renseignements est hélas
on a dû les aider même déposé des
plaintes parce qu'il ya des gens qui ne
comprennent pas parfaitement bien ne
parle pas du tout dans la française mais
touristes italiens souvent intrigués qui
n'hésite pas à la bordée c'est une
protection en plus on se sent quand même
benjamin policiers hollandais progrès
police espagnole jeudi police française
au total une quinzaine de policiers
européens circulent sur les lieux
touristiques comme ici à versailles mais
questions sont parfois très pratique il
faut qu'elle vérifie avec le
gouvernement espagnol les modalités
d'entrée au territoire espagnol pour les
chiens qu'ils soient vaccinés traduction
quasi simultanées et quand ils discutent
ensemble cela ressemble parfois à un
cours de droit européen comparer les
différences pour interpeller les gens
s'il peut faire usage de la force
l'usagé des armes quel équipement et
disposent les durées de garde à vue
cette expérience pourrait être étendue à
tous les lieux touristiques en europe et
lors des grandes manifestations
culturelles et sportives
c'est une étude très sérieuse du
ministère britannique des affaires
étrangères qui s'inquiète du
comportement qualifié d' inapproprié de
ses ressortissants dans ce qu'ils sont
en vacances à l'étranger ces
comportements sont vu la plupart du
temps une consommation excessive
d'alcool et véhiculent une image plutôt
négative des sujets de sa très gracieuse
majesté reportage armes goûter et le
rang des bois lorsque le soleil se
couche
les britanniques se lève pour faire la
fête et deviennent le cauchemar des
autorités locales
chaque été comme ici en crète
l'image ne relève pas du cliché je me
suis coupé et comment je ne sais pas
loin des parents ils viennent pour voir
et la nuit se termine souvent en bagarre
l'an dernier quatre mille six cents
jeunes britanniques ont été arrêtés hors
du royaume uni agression viol
tous les matins se mettre à distribuer
des pilules du lendemain et il entend la
même histoire dit toujours j'ai trop bu
la nuit dernière et ce matin il y avait
dans mon lit trois ou quatre hommes
première destination l'espagne 17
millions de britanniques
les campagnes de sensibilisation ne
suffisent pas et les agents se
reconnaissent leur impuissance ce
difficile de dire aux gens de ne pas
trop voir nos clients sont des adultes
et avec le nombre important de voyageurs
certains se retrouvent forcément à des
situations dangereuses
on ne peut pas l'éviter en angleterre la
consommation dans les pubs seront aussi
une tournure inquiétante
en 15 ans le nombre de morts liés à
l'alcool a quasiment doublé les anglais
boivent trop et surtout trop vite
jusqu'à quatre vies par personne
certains soirs la bière traditionnelle
est devenu un problème de santé publique
et en france la prudence va s'imposer
sur les routes il y aura beaucoup de
circulation en cette fin de semaine
c'est surtout dans le sens des retours
que les routes seront chargées samedi
est classé rouge vous le voyez la
sécurité routière estime en tout état de
cause que ce long week-end nous donnera
lieu à un trafic important première
vendors jariza lé tout on a commencé à
accueillir cette nuit le muscat raisin
destiné à élaborer le vin blanc doux
naturels qui porte le même nom dans le
reste de la région les vendanges
devraient commencer dans huit jours
myler gagner ici est le paquet
les nuits de pleine lune ou presque un
ballet de monstrueuses machines parade
dans les vignes secouée violemment et
livre le petit grain doré et fruité qui
sera recueillie dans les entrailles de
la bête depuis hier soir 23 heures on
vendange le muscat à rivesaltes
quand il fait chaud se joue s'oxyde le
fait de vendanger la nuit
on essaie températures qui sont proches
de 20 voire même en dessous de 20 donc
là le jus est protégé beaucoup plus
longtemps
au petit jour et jusqu'en fin de matinée
les mains des saisonniers prennent le
relais une grappe sur deux est cueilli
pour le muscat sec le reste sera dédiée
au vin doux tout ce que la machine ne
peut pas attraper s'aggrave à 30 une
trentaine de centimètres du sol
nous on enlève à la main
systématiquement sur fond de crise
viticole avec plus de 25 mille hectares
de vignes arrachées dans le languedoc en
deux ans cette exploitation a dû se
tourner vers l'étranger
notre salut
qui a essentiellement à l'export nous
sommes actuellement présent sur une
quarantaine de pays à l'étranger
l'essai actuellement c'est ce qui me
permet de faire la différence parce
qu'actuellement il ya au niveau national
il ya une régression énorme au niveau de
la consommation du vin des étrangers qui
plébiscitent le muscat sec de rivesaltes
pour sa teneur en sucre aux alentours de
12 et nuit pour cent et sans acidité ces
cellules du raisin accuse être pressé
donc c'est forcément de réfuter je suis
intéressé surtout cette vivacité sa
fraîcheur il ya quand même beaucoup
d'acidité c'est ce que l'on recherchait
trop tôt encore pour se prononcer sur le
millésime 2008
il faudra attendre encore deux semaines
que le jus de raisin fermente pour avoir
le verdict retour à pékin pour faire le
point sur les autres médailles
françaises car la journée a été faste
dans le sillage d'alain bernard sacré
champion olympique
d'autres ont été couronnées de bronze
surface majesty c est jean francois
monier bronzage intégral deuxième finale
2e podiums pour hugues duboscq et le
havrais ne s'en lasse pas le bronze
suffit à son bonheur
déjà 3e sur 100 m brasse hugues duboscq
c'était mal c'est matin pour doubler sur
200 m
avec sa médaille d'athènes il porte son
total à trois records pour un nageur
tricolore
je fais ma course et une fois que touche
le mur je regarde ce que je suis et à ce
moment là bas c'est l'explosion de joie
parce que faire de médailles dans une
olympiade
je suis vraiment content là une seule
médaille même de bronze peut suffire les
larmes de stéphanie possamaï disent tous
des émotions d'olympic
son entraîneur l'a poussé dans ses
derniers retranchements pour renverser
l'espagnol semble miguel qu'elle n'avait
jamais battue
l'ajout de cadres de sud ouest a eu
besoin de cet aiguillon
c'est un combat de quatre ans qui
s'achève par une victoire
ça fait 20 ans je fais du judo et voilà
c'est le fruit de 25 du dos et c'est
énorme
et quand la médaille inattendue les
effusions n'ont plus de limites
benoît caranobe a rapporté à la france
son premier podium dans le concours
général de gymnastique depuis 88 ans
des six agrès au programme le sol a fait
la différence à deux doigts de la
perfection de bronze
certains diront c'est qu'une médaille de
bronze mais pour moi c'est non
ces moments-là représente des années
d'efforts de souffrance parfois à l'or
le métal est toujours précieux la france
continue sa remontée dans le tableau des
médailles en passant au neuvième rang
contre le 12e hier changement science du
tableau après la chine et les etats unis
c'est désormais l'allemagne et
troisièmement avec cette médaille d'or
on le sait les chinois n'ont pas hésité
à raser une partie de pékin historique
pour moderniser la ville en vue des jeux
olympiques
les ide restent tout de même des
quartiers non rénovées dans la capitale
alors faute de temps des murs ont été
construits pour cacher la misère aux
yeux des visiteurs occidentaux à côté de
la place se tiennent elles mêmes ou même
nom certaines rues commerçantes
reportage pascal golomer et celle un job
il est apparu un beau jour sans
explication le long d'un grand boulevard
au sud de tiananmen
ce mur d'enceinte flambant neuf inspiré
de l'architecturé traditionnelle ne sert
à rien si ce n'est à masquer les
boutiques et les immeubles qui avaient
jusqu'à lors
il n'y en sur eux le mur c'est
soi-disant un mur de décoration mais en
fait c'est pour cacher la misère cachée
les maisons en mauvais état que ceux qui
passent devant ne voit plus rien en fait
le quartier doit être détruit mais les
autorités locales n'ont pas réussi à
faire partir tous les habitants avant
les jeux olympiques problèmes
d'indemnisation
en attendant ce mur sauvera les
apparences et tant pis pour ceux qui
c'est normal que nous les commerçants
soient contre ce mur parce que c'est
très bon pour nos affaires
le mur est tellement haut les passants
ne peuvent plus voir s'il y à
l'intérieur du magasin durant les jeux
les visiteurs ne doivent voir que ce que
les autorités sont fiers de montrer les
chantiers sont donc dissimulé derrière
de grandes palissades la grande rue de
tianmen elle a été ouverte juste à temps
la veille de la cérémonie d'ouverture
ici tout a été rasé puis totalement
reconstruit imitation anciens les
magasins ne sont pas encore ouverts et
ce qui n'est pas présentables est bien
dissimulé le public chinois lui après si
on change la société change
bien sûr dans notre coeur on voudrait
tous réservés mais certaines choses
anciennes
on ne peut rien faire pour ces jeux
pékin voulait la plus belle vitrine
possible quitte à cacher ce qui ne
pouvait pas se reconstruit tout de suite
comme un décors en trompe l'oeil pour
faire illusion pendant deux semaines
seulement une journée dans la capitale
olympique s'est aussi fait de bonheur et
de contrariétés a commencé par une météo
tropicale
la pluie s'est abattue sur pékin
christophe du sillon en chine 2008 c'est
l'année du rat mais aujourd'hui à pékin
c'était la matinée du temps de cochon
car le temps était à l'orage aux trombes
d'eau et au parent a pris le pékinois et
trempé comme une soupe laclais terrain
c'est au tir il tombe des cordes à son
arc au beach-volley liégeoise en moyenne
maillot de bain à leur tout petit
maillot de corps l'aviron le canoë kayak
sont reportés d'autres épreuves suspendu
c'était l'heure de la glorieuse
incertitude du sport et de la météo et à
feurs avait toujours pékin à la lutte
le temps aussi était à l'orage au moment
de la cérémonie protocolaire le suédois
abrahamian descend soudainement du
podium et abandonne sa médaille de
bronze sur le tapis en signe de
protestation à cause d'une décision
d'arbitrage est contesté depuis le matin
en quelque sorte c'était sa lutte finale
le court central en matinée sous les
gouttes et l'après midi des goûters
comme le suisse federer qui comptait se
refaire une santé olympique aux jeux et
qui est éliminée dès les quarts de
finale en deux sets par l'américain
james blake pour federer 2008 est
l'année du rat d'égout et ta soeur avait
toujours pékin en finale du 200 m
papillon drôle de mésaventure pour la
française aurore mongel qui a vu arriver
dans son couloir
un objet volant globalement identifié un
mini tambourin venus des tribunes
ils achètent par un supporter un peu
trop énergique la française qui termine
6e n'a pas porté réclamation la classe
en dépit d'une performance sans tambour
ni trompette
football et supporter du paris saint
germain sont soulagés le club est
finalement autorisé à participer à la
coupe de la ligue
c'est ce qu'a décidé cet après midi le
tribunal administratif de paris
on se rappelle que la fédération de
football avait voulu exclure le psg de
la coupe après la banderole anti ch'tis
déployée lors de la finale en mars
dernier aujourd'hui de ce séminaire a
considéré la sanction disproportionnée
et puis en ligue des champions bon
démarrage pour l'olympique de marseille
qui a battu hier les norvégiens de
bergen 1 à 0 lors du 3e tour
préliminaire aller l'om s'est imposé
grâce à bruno cheyrou vous voyez match
retour le 27 août au stade vélodrome 28e
festival de piano de la roque d'anthéron
dans le luberon les concerts comme
chaque année se tiennent en plein air
mais peu à peu les lieux de
représentations s'étendent
reportage sur place isabelle bechler et
frédéric bazille à la roque d'anthéron
sous les platanes centenaires les
effluves de musique n'a timide pas les
cigales
chaque matin les mélomanes peuvent
assister gratuitement au masters classes
ici de jeunes interprètes du japon sont
accompagnés dans leur apprentissage par
des concertistes confirmé les trois
membres du trio wanderer
c'est une balade donc ça veut dire qu'il
se passe des choses mais on se promène
dans le temps de manière un peu
tranquille une balade des prunes course
bon bah ça c'est fortis immo mais si tu
veux mais là j'ai le violent c'est très
violent rejet très bon c'est très chaud
de son on a besoin d'un peu plus
d'aspérités une résidence de dix jours à
la roque d'anthéron très riche en
expérience pour le duo japonais à
l'extérieur et si ya des vents et un
cigare ce soir elles joueront
gratuitement dans le village de plan
d'orgon
pendant que leurs professeurs se
produiront eux au temple de lourmarin
les trois solistes travaillent ensemble
depuis 20 ans il répète néanmoins pour
prendre possession du lieu est équilibré
leur son après auxerre flop la trinité
c'est dire c'est notre trois
personnalités très distinctes dans un
tout où comment transmettre la chimie de
la musique de chambre
e
quant à nos deux jeunes musiciennes
japonaises concernées elles se
retrouvent spectatrice de la grande
scène du soir au château de florans
l'épicentre de ce festival de la roque
d'anthéron qui essaime désormais pendant
trois semaines et surtout le lubéron
avant de nous quitter je vous rappelle
la principale information de cette
journée alain bernard n'a pas failli
dans l'épreuve reine de la natation le
100 m nage libre il a été sacré ce matin
champion olympique en 47 secondes et 21h
thiem c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo de tania young suivi du
poids route de julien pascal 20h50
secret d'histoire ses fans vers nous
parlera de napoléon et des femmes
demain 13h vous avez rendez vous avec la
pétulante sophie le sang puis à 20h avec
olivier galzi pour tout le week end
je vous retrouve lundi à 20h très bonne
soirée à tous sera
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr
votre soirée sur